[Music]
the weekend release the new song today
with I'm going to screw this up if that
sustained justice office teens
applicants office teen called lost in
the fire a lot of people are wondering
if and one of the lyrics he's dissing
Drake of course Drake kind of son he
kept hidden but was forced to address it
up to push a tee revealed Drake was a
dad in this track will now listen to
this line if the weekend has in a new
song
oh okay so do you think that that was a
district a lot of people on Twitter do
there's a couple reactions the weekend
is shading Drake I can't handle both my
favs beefing and then Drake versus the
weekend it's pretty much a Canadian
civil war yeah come on guys can't do
that for Canadians family here
well like I mean what else could that
line he's using the exact language that
you don't understand hiding a baby like
unless I mean if that's just a random
line that we can came up with insider
like now he's realizing like oh right
that could be about drink but here's
like the and the sympathetic side of me
like we're going after somebody's baby I
know kids baby yeah and you wonder cuz I
mean leftist they've collaborated before
us looking like I know I remember a
couple songs they've had but they've had
about like five or six songs are they
collaborating with over the past like I
guess about eight or nine years yeah
they've worked with each other before I
mean it's not a OB oxo yeah I don't
think like I wouldn't say that gets a
huge disc at Drake it's more like the
circumstance like well I don't know the
current like climate the way the way
that singers and rappers hip-hop artists
throw distance at each other now that is
essentially what that is like that is a
line in the song because now you hear
like Kanye here's a line in the song and
goes nuts right for like two months
about it right like that's the way these
things are now and yeah the thing about
like kind of going Africa at least it's
not necessary insulting the kid he's
more like talking about the scenario
that was him having a child yeah yeah
Joyce's major shade that Kim says let
the beef begin
Siobhan says oh wow just wow I'll leave
kids over your BS brandis's why not
Drake needs to be dissed people are
really starting to turn on Drake yes
you're a so people are not enjoying our
drink has been the handling things hold
in but then you're out you're at the
club and the song comes on and you're
like I love this song and you're like
yeah like if you're any of these people
that are doing great right now you're
like oh how the town somewhere and
somebody Drake comes on and you're in in
my senior wrong
so come on you know paula has a good
solution for this though just this time
for a snowball fight I'm gonna do it
that'd be like a pay-per-view event
outlined in the weekend direct the video
they'll be amazing video ok break a very
Canadian uh solution to the problem
you